en direct des rues de paris thomas
bonnet notre reporter thomas abonnés
bonjour vous êtes tout près de la gare
montparnasse à midi ça y est les
français doivent rester chez eux
aujourd'hui ne vont pas encore être
verbalisé selon la porte parole du
gouvernement comment ça se passe autour
de vous est ce que la police est
présente et ce qu'il y ait encore des
passants dans la rue
oui voilà vingt minutes maintenant que
ces mesures de restrictions de
déplacements sont entrées en vigueur il
ya encore du monde sur le parvis de la
gare montparnasse du monde qui
continuent d'arriver pour et bien
quitter la région parisienne c'est le
but d'un certain nombre de franciliens
qui ne souhaitent pas vivre ce
confinement en région parisienne
certains donc vont prendre le train
direction
or ce qui concerne la gare montparnasse
direction l'ouest de la france je peux
vous dire que l'intérieur de la gare
montparnasse a des allures de jour de
départs de vacances pour les passagers
il ya beaucoup de monde ils ne
respectent pas tous les distances de
sécurité ce qui peut laisser craindre
une propagation du virus on a interrogé
certains de ces voyageurs je vous
propose de les écouter
de la faire en vélo et je suis rentré
pour ce travail
ce qui a pu très cuite et le français a
du mal avec ce au lendemain
donc c'est toujours trop tard mais on
mérite existait maintenant tous les
acquittés
certains
stressé angoissé la même quand je suis à
pattes ailées travail
présent et donc
reste à la maison
pas s'occuper
mais vous avez des présidents voilà on
va simplement écouter les consignes
la plus depuis que nous sommes sur le
parvis de la gare montparnasse qu'on a
pu assister à des patrouilles de police
des renforts de police sont arrivés
depuis le début de le plier la fin de la
matinée pour l'entrée en vigueur de ces
mesures de confinement pour le moment on
n'a pas assisté au moindre contrôle de
la part de ces policiers ici auprès des
voyageurs des voyageurs qui pour
certains n'ont pas très bien compris les
restrictions de déplacements beaucoup
nous demandent quel est le papier la
fameuse dérogation dont il faut être en
possession pour pouvoir se déplacer je
vous le rappelle cette attestation de
déplacement dérogatoire c'est celle ci
qui est disponible sur la plupart des
sites gouvernementaux il faut la remplir
et donc justifier d'une raison
justifiable et accepté par les autorités
pour pouvoir se déplacer
parmi ces raisons je vous le rappelle se
déplaçait pour des raisons
professionnelles les achats de première
nécessité des rendez vous médicaux
la garde des enfants encore la pratique
d'exercices physiques à proximité de son
habitation voilà donc pour ces
restrictions de déplacements je vous le
rappelle pour le moment l'amande
encourus par les personnes qui ne
justifieraient pas de leurs déplacements
et de la somme de 38 euros
elle sera très prochainement passer au
montant de 135 euros
thomas bonnin en direct du parvis de la
gare montparnasse merci pour toutes ces
précisions